and get quick and dirty does for our
lotto meet Nick Carter a zoosk zerstöre
ihren Kot vor I Initialen on its
mark if I am I their sexiest man alive
vas is their order noch einen Yanni's
are gangs in don't bomb octoman no
comment cela  Musik oder verschiedene Spaziergänge
Gewässer wir bekommen eine mittelalterliche Form von ihnen
bedeutet das ja eigentlich nicht einfach
das ist unser Finale es geht um das
Echte mit harmlosen Fragen und nicht so
harmlosen Fragen richtige sind ein bisschen
fies du kannst wählen gib es
dir gut  kann es drehen, ja, ich werde einfach da
rauskommen,
warum spielst du
nur kommerzielle Musik, sehr kommerzielle Musik,
böse, also habe ich kommerzielle Musik
mit den Backstreet Boys gemacht, aber wenn
ich meine Soloplatte mache, habe ich nur
Musik gemacht, die ich will  Ist es mir wirklich
egal, was Kritiker sagen oder Leute sagen,
weil ich es einfach so singen möchte und ich
habe alle Songs meines Albums geschrieben, also
Jungs, wir machen
bis zu einem gewissen Grad auch kommerzielle Musik, aber
wir versuchen es immer  g, an die Grenzen zu gehen,
also denke ich, es ist eine Frage des
persönlichen Geschmacks.
Sie wissen, was Sie von Werbung halten,
denn heutzutage sind wir nicht
mehr so ​​kommerziell, weil es schwer ist
, im Radio zu kommen, okay, aber es ist die Musik, die
Sie mögen, die ich liebe  Musik als kommerzielle
Musik eine andere Popmusik Popmusik ist
dieser Fluch okay du kannst ein oder
zwei mehr auswählen ist mir egal okay du hast keine
Angst vor der fiesen Frage
du warst der sexieste Mann der Welt
was bist du jetzt ich bin  Mann, das war
sexy,
was durch eine ziemlich schlechte Phase gegangen ist, und ich
bekomme meinen sexy Rücken zurück.
Ich kenne meine Bilder in letzter Zeit nicht
, das ist ziemlich gut, haha, ok, ok, also vielen Dank, danke, dass
du dich zu dir gesellt hast